the Libyan Iron and Steel company or
lisco is one of the largest industrial
firms in North Africa it's an important
source of income for many in the western
city of misrata directly employing more
than 7 000 people
this is lisco's beating heart
more than 1.7 million tons of steel
products are produced here every year
but the company says it can do even more
we have faced many challenges because of
the political situation at the moment
we're not operating at full capacity a
stability is achieved and government
projects resume we estimate demand for
steel products with at least double
lisco was a major supplier to the
government's development program but
most State projects like this 5 000
housing unit development were suspended
during the armed revolution of 2011.
before that foreign companies were
contracted by the Libyan state to build
more than three hundred thousand housing
units across the country but they left
in 2011 and have yet to come back more
than 1800 development projects have been
halted with the lack of affordable
government housing home prices in Libya
have gradually increased that's made it
difficult for many to afford a new home
works for the housing Ministry in
masrata
there are so many young men who have not
been able to get married because they
cannot afford homes if this project was
to finish more than 5 000 families will
benefit
this conference in Tripoli discussed
plans to resume work on the thousands of
suspended development projects in Libya
but there are challenges ahead
there are problems the first is the
security situation foreign companies
won't return unless they feel safe then
there's the money for these projects it
has to be available many of the
companies want to be compensated for the
losses they incurred before they return
contracts must be renegotiated
life has not been easy for millions of
libyans in recent years conflict and
divisions have made it difficult for
authorities to focus on development
Libya has Africa's largest crude oil
reserves and should be a prosperous
country but the unemployment rate is
estimated to be around 20 percent many
here are waiting for that to change soon
and bring stability with it in return
they hope to find jobs and more
affordable housing Malik trainer Al
Jazeera maserata